hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american mystery and fiction movie
with an amazing plot called before i
fall
the movie starts with a beautiful young
girl samantha who wakes on february 12th
she checks a message from her best
friend telling her that today is
february 12th which is known as cupid's
day
she is picked up by one of her best
friends lindsay to go to school they
also pick up the rest of their best
friends named ally and elodie in the car
they are excited about sam's plans to
lose her virginity to her boyfriend rob
that night
at school they see all the students are
preparing roses to give to their loved
ones
during class the students distribute
roses to each other to celebrate the
cupid's day
sam is getting one from rob and another
roses from a boy named ken a former
grade school friend who is secretly in
love with her after class kent suddenly
invites her to a party at his house but
she is unenthusiastic with his
invitation
during lunch the girls make fun of julia
an outsider girl who they view as a
psycho in the school
at night they dress up together before
going to the party
lindsay asks sam about her first night
she tells her not to worry because rob
is a good guy
at the party sam meets her boyfriend who
accidentally spills his drink on her
shirt because he's drunk so she decides
to go back with her friends
not long after juliet shows up at the
party lindsay immediately confronts her
in the two fight resulting in many of
the guests dousing juliet with beer
humiliated she leaves the place in tears
as sam and her friends are driving back
from the party the car crashes into
something and apparently kills all of
them the next morning sam wakes in her
room on cupid's day again
thinking the previous day was just a
nightmare sam continues on with her day
but finds similarities to the events
that happened that day such as her
wearing the same clothes and receiving
the same flowers from kent
that night she is doing the same thing
at the party except before she returns
to her friends she initially checks
kent's room
even so the crash happens again after
they leave the party
sam wakes up on the same day at the same
place again
the difference is at school she refuses
kent's invitation for the party
realizing she is in a time loop she
convinces the group to have a sleepover
instead of going to the party they are
able to avoid the crash but later they
still find out that juliet commits
suicide in that night with sam also
discovering that lindsay and julia were
once best friends
even though sam manages to avoid the
crash she continues to live through the
same day over and over again
realizing that nothing she does matters
she starts doing whatever she wants that
day first she hears her grievances with
everyone she knows including her best
friends
she also disobeys the teacher who is
teaching in the class
later she attempts to make amends with
anna a student she had bullied
somehow she also becomes closer to kent
during the loop
soon she drifts away from her friend and
ends up trying her first sexual
experience with rob at the party
resulting in a bad experience
after the unsatisfying experience ken
suddenly finds her crying in his room
he comforts her and later sam apologizes
to him for what she has done all this
time
he also takes care of her sleeping in
his room
the next day she begins to realize that
she wants to make her days more valuable
for herself and others by trying to
spend more quality time with the one she
loves
in the morning she starts to play with
her little sister whom she has rarely
paid attention to
she also spends dinner with her whole
family
finally she knows that she has to do
something useful in her life
in the next loop at the party sam and
can't remember their earlier friendship
with kent recalling how she had
heroically defended him from a bully
after his father died
since then he had resolved to one day be
her hero
afterward they romantically share a kiss
after a while she hears the fight
between lindsay and juliet from the hall
she decides to chase after julia through
the woods
she tries to apologize and learns from
juliet that lindsay's misery is from her
parents fight and divorce causing her to
start wetting her bed
when the two were on a camping trip and
lindsey went her sleeping bag she blamed
juliet and had been bullying her ever
since in the end juliette still insists
on committing suicide by running in
front of lindsay's car horrifying sam
and making her realize that it was julia
who was hit by the car on the original
day
sam wakes up again feeling calm and
understanding knowing what she must do
to end the loop
she resolves to be kind and considerate
as she goes about her day
in the morning she immediately treats
her parents well
she tells her friends why she loves them
at school and she also sends roses to
both juliet and ken and ends up breaking
up with rob
and at the party she finds and kisses
kent straight away and tells him that
she loves him so much
she again intervenes to save juliet in
the woods but when juliet attempts to
kill herself by running into traffic sam
instantly pushes her out of the way at
the last second resulting in her being
killed by a truck
as she dies she remembers all the good
memories she has had during her entire
life
and then sam's spirit sees juliet
standing over her body sadly saying that
sam saved her sam thankfully states no
you saved me the moral of the story is
don't waste your time for unnecessary
things spend it with your family and the
people you loved
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching